seit dem Morgen werden aus dem
Gazastreifen heraus Raketen auf Israel
abgeschossen es ist der größte Angriff
auf Israel seit Jahren aus der Luft am
Boden und von der See die
Terrororganisation Hamas hat diesen Tag
zum Zitat Tag der Schlacht erklärt nach
israelischen Angaben wurden 2200 Raketen
auf Israel abgefeuert das mit
Luftangriffen auf Gaza
reagierte guten Tag liebe Zuschauer aus
dem Bonner phönixstudio es ist offenbar
ein sehr großer gut koordinierter
Angriff auf Israel mindestens 22
Israelis sind getötet und mehr als 200
verletzt worden israelische Medien
berichten davon dass 60 palästinensische
Terroristen an 14 Orten beteiligt sind
offenbar werden von den Terroristen auch
gezielt Israelis entführt und beschossen
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu berief eine
Krisensitzung der Sicherheitskräfte ein
er sagt israel sei im
Krieg Explosionen und Feuer in askelon
im Süden Israels ein Raketenangriff der
das Land am Morgen überrascht seit 6:30
Uhr Ortszeit schießt die
palästinensische Hamas Raketen ausgaser
auf Israel mehr als 3000 sind es nach
israelischen Angaben inzwischen bislang
gibt es in Israel mehr als 22 Todesopfer
verletzte etwa 60 bewaffnete Kämpfer der
Hamas durchbrechen zudem den Grenzzaun
von Gaza nach Israel nehmen israelische
Soldaten als Geiseln es gibt Berichte
über Kämpfe in israelischen Orten nahe
des gasastreifens sowohl Israels
Premierminister Netanyahu als auch sein
Verteidigungsminister sprechen
inzwischen von Krieg die Hamas hat heute
früh einen schweren Fehler begangen und
einen Krieg gegen Israel gestartet
Soldaten des israelischen Militärs
kämpfen inzwischen an Orten an denen wir
angegriffen wurden ich rufe alle auf
sich an die Anweisung der
heimatfrontbehörde zu
halten die palästinensische Hamas
spricht von einer Operation gegen die
Verbrechen Israels ruft palästinensische
Israelis auf sich zu beteiligen
inzwischen hat Israel mit Gegenangriffen
begonnen auch vom Einsatz von
israelischen Soldaten in Gaza ist die
Rede der einzige internationale
Flughafen Israels nah Tel Aviv wurde
geschlossen es sind Bilder des Terrors
und des Krieges Israel wird massiv
angegriffen das ist ein Livebild hier im
Hintergrund aus Gaza Stadt dem
Palästinensergebiet wir sehen
Rauchsäulen denn Israel antwortet mit
Luftangriffen wie ist die Situation in
Tel Aviv von dort berichtet die Kollegin
Sofie von der
TAN die Lage ist nach wie vor
unübersichtlich es gibt nach wie vor
Raketenangriffe aus dem Gazastreifen
auch Luftangriffe Israels auf den
Gazastreifen und die sozialen Netzwerke
sind voll mit Videos wie
palästinensische Kämpfer Israelis
verschleppen in den Gazastreifen das
sind halils sehr grausame Szenen und es
gibt nach wie vor auch noch
palästinensische Kämpfer in israelischen
Orten da dringen verzweifelte Anrufe von
Israelis die sich verschanzen in ihren
Bunkern raus und fragen wo ist das
Militär wo ist die Polizei das ist es
grundsätzlich mal zu einer großen
Eskalation oder einer größeren
Eskalation kommen würde das ist nicht so
überraschend in Anbetracht der sehr
aufgeheizen Situation aber dass das
jetzt in dieser Form in dieser
Heftigkeit zu diesem Zeitpunkt passieren
würde das hat wohl auch die israelischen
Sicherheitsbehörden überrascht viele
dürfte das Erinnern an den jomkipur
Krieg den Überraschungsangriff von
Syrien und Ägypten vor genau
Jahren die Tatsache dass
palästinensische Kämpfer in israelischen
Orten sind und dass die H hier die
treibende Kraft ist zeigt dass das eine
andere Qualität ist hat als das was wir
in den vergangenen Monaten gesehen haben
und dass da auch großes
Eskalationspotenzial ist und die große
Frage ist auch was passiert an der
zweiten großen Front Israels im Norden
zum Libanon was macht die hesbollah
jetzt im Libanon ja soweit s viiel von
der TAN aus Tel Aviv der Bundeskanzler
zeigt sich entsetzt über die Angriffe
auf Israel und sagt deutschland stehe
solidarisch an der Seite Israels und
Außenministerin berbock hat den massiven
Raketenbeschuss aus dem Gazastreifen auf
Israel Zitat aufs Schärfste verurteilt
im Studio begrüße ich jetzt hansdieter
hummann den Sicherheitsexperten und
Experten für internationale Politik mit
der diplomatischen Vergangenheit schön
dass sie an diesem
denkwürdigen an diesem fürchterlichen
Tag für Israel an diesem Samstag ins
Studio gekommen sind und in Berlin
begrüße ich Daniel Gerlach er ist der
naostexperte und Publizist gut guten Tag
auch Ihnen Herr
Gerlach ja vielen Dank zunächst die
erste Frage an Sie Herr Gerlach es
scheint ja offenbar so ein wirklich
massiver Angriff zu sein kann man sagen
dass die Strippenzieher der Hamas und
andere Leute die da im Hintergrund
möglicherweise mitmitschen tatsächlich
diesen Tag 50 Jahre nach jonkipur ganz
bewusst und gezielt gewählt
haben ja davon ist auszugehen die
Symbolik ist ja offensichtlich und so
wird es auch in weiten Teilen der
arabischen Welt aufgenommen wir dürfen
nicht vergessen der JOM kipur Krieg vor
50 Jahren ist hat zwar mit einem Sieg
der Israelis geendet aber es war ein
pyussieg und für viele Menschen in der
arabischen Welt war der jomipurkrieg vor
50 Jahren eigentlich ein Sieg der
arabischen Seite mit dem man Israel
langfristig politische Konzessionen
abbringen konnte und die Symbolik ist
ist natürlich da auf der anderen Seite
muss man sagen es hat sich in den
letzten Wochen einiges hochgeschaukelt
und es kommen hier viele Konfliktlinien
und und Entwicklungen übereinander
äh die es nicht verwunderlich machen
dass es zu einer militärischen
Eskalation kommt die die die die
Präzision dieser Kommandoaktion ist
tatsächlich bemerkenswert und es ist
auch bemerkenswert dass die israelischen
Geheimdienste das offensichtlich nicht
so voraussehen konnten obwohl es einige
Hinweise gab vor einen Tagen hat man z.B
den den Grenzübertritt von von von Gaza
insch ins israelische Kernland
geschlossen das kann auch mit
nachrichtendienstlichen Informationen zu
tun gehabt haben auf palästinensischer
Seite wurde das als Schikane und
politische Geste interpretiert es hat
sich in einiges entwickelt in den
letzten Wochen was auf eine militärische
Eskalation zu hinwies aber dass es in
dieser durchgeplanten Kommandoaktion
enden würde damit hat man in Israel ganz
bestimmt nicht ja offenbar eine riesige
Kommandoaktion Herr Humann aus dem
Gasastreifen heraus wir haben ja gerade
das Livebild gesehen aus dem
gaserstreifen wie ist das möglich dass
offenbar tausende von raket en
abgeschossen werden können und
wahrscheinlich mehr als 60 Terroristen
nach Israel hinein gelangen können wie
ist so etwas möglich dass möglicherweise
die Israelis davon überrascht sind ja
das hat schon eine neue Qualität dieser
Angriff es hat das muss man allerdings
auch sagen ja seitdem die Hamas die
Macht übernommen hat im Gazastreifen
immer wieder Waffengänge gegeben 2008
2009 2012 2014 aber das ist hier eine äh
neue Qualität vor allem weil nicht nur
Raketen äh geflogen sind sondern eben
auch Kämpfer auf israelischen Gebiet
sind in derort askelon haben wir gerade
gehört das ist schon eine neue Qualität
vor allem wie haben die den Grenzzaun
zwischen Gaza und Israel überwinden das
ist ein ziemlich moderner Grenzzaun der
tief in die Erde geht sind mit Zensoren
ausgestattet ist also das sind schon
fragen die sich die die israelischen
sicher
m Herr gellach sie haben ja die aktuelle
Situation auch die Reaktionen aus der
arabischen Welt gerade angesprochen wie
fallen die denn
aus unterschiedlich ähm man ist
natürlich
schockiert teilweise aber man ist auch
dann wiederum nicht verwundert wenn sie
sich gerade die Staaten angucken die in
den der letzten Zeit immer vermittelt
haben zwischen Israel und der Hamas also
insbesondere Ägypten und die Kataris
dann habe ich ehrlich gesagt den
Eindruck dass man sehr wenig verwundert
ist darüber dass es zu einer Eskalation
kommt und dass man in den letzten Wochen
auch einiges versucht hat um das zu
verhindern ähm aber jetzt sich eben auch
nicht darüber wundert dass es passiert
auch wenn das Ausmaß der Operation auch
auf der arabischen Seite für
Verwunderung sorgt ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass es viele Menschen gibt
auf den im arabischen Lager die das
obwohl es eine blutige und brutale
Aktion ist mit einer gewissen Sympathie
sehen weil sie äh weil die Hamas damit
demonstriert dass Israel nicht
unverbundbar ist in den letzten Jahren
hat der ostkonflikt auf israelischer
Seite kaum noch eine Rolle gespielt und
man nur noch mit sich selbst beschäftigt
und und fühlte sich Hauch überleg also
ha haush hoch überlegen Verzeigung und
das hat sich eben jetzt durch diese
Aktion natürlich schlagartig geändert es
ist auch Herr Gerlach eine andere ich
sag jetzt mal
Qualität nicht nur
Raketenbeschuss jetzt haben wir Liebe
Regie jetzt haben wir Ton Aussetzer von
Herrn Gerlach er ist teilweise nicht zu
verstehen ich versuch's noch mal Herr
Gerlach in Berlin können sie mich hören
ich kann sie hören ja ich wollte fragen
es gibt im Internet tatsächlich Szenen
wo Terroristen gezielt offenbar Jagd auf
israelisch sprich auf Juden machen
offensichtlich es gibt Bilder wo eine
Frau von solchen Terroristen in ein Auto
gezerrt wird in einen Pickup und dann
entführt wird
kann es sein dass die Hammers jetzt
sozusagen eine neue Qualität von Terror
gegen israelische Zivilbevölkerung
fährt das kann man sagen es hat solche
Versuche auch in der Vergangenheit
gegeben was ich bemerkenswert finde ist
es gibt eine sehr sehr populäre auch
international populäre Thriller Serie
die heißt fauda und die läuft unter
anderem auf Netflix und die die das
erfolgreichste Exportprodukt der
Israelis und in dieser Serie können Sie
dieses Szenario was wir jetzt in Israel
erleben eigentlich äh wird da schon
vorgeführt das heißt also die die
diebuchautoren die die israelische
Situation und die palästinensische auch
sehr gut kennen haben im Grunde ein
solches Szenario schon beschrieben und
äh umso heftiger ist es natürlich für
die israelischen Sicherheitsdienste dass
sie es offensichtlich nicht ernst
genommen haben nicht vorausgesehen haben
oder was noch schlimmer wäre obwohl sie
mit einem Szenario wie diesem rechnen
konnten es eben nicht verhindern konnten
das wird auf israelischer Seite
natürlich sehr sehr äh starke Folgen
haben und die Politik wird definitiv die
Nachrichtendienste dafür auch wird ihen
die Schuld dafür geben denn zwischen der
Politik und den Nachrichtendiensten hat
es aus anderen Gründen in der letzten
Zeit erhebliche Zerwürfnisse gegeben und
ich bin sicher dass wenn der der Krieg
jetzt losgeht die israelische Führung
auch mit den nachrichtenchefs in dieser
Angelegenheit abrechnen wird Herr hmann
jetzt hat der Ministerpräsident netaniao
ja quasi den Kriegszustand ausgerufen er
hat ja gesagt Israel ist jetzt im Krieg
was bedeutet das denn jetzt ganz formal
das bedeutet dass er Reservisten
einziehen kann und es war die Rede von
mereren 1000 Reservisten die einziehen
kann wenn den Kriegs äh Zustand ähm
erklärt und das geschieht gerade das
heißt Israel nimmt diesen Angriff sehr
ernst mhm aber militärisch ist da ja
nichts zu gewinnen für die Hamas also
für diese Terroristen sie können
fürchterliches blutbart offensichtlich
sind sie ja schon dabei anrichten
Menschen entführen es heißt die in
Meldung offenbar sind auch israelische
Soldaten in die Hände der Hamas äh
gefallen also man kann damit Israel
erpressen aber es ist ja ja militärisch
nichts zu gewinnen welches Ziel hat man
denn politisch so man denn bei
Terroristen von politischen Zielen
sprechen kann ja ich glaube da müssen
man den Blick über die über den
giserstreifen hinausrichten also die
Zustände im giserstreifen sind Grund
genug für dafür dass der Hass
immer weiter zugenommen hat da wohen 2
Millionen Menschen in in bitterer Armut
60% der Jugendlichen sind arbeitslos da
haben sie ein unglaubliches Potenzial
ähm an an
Aggressivität aber ich glaube man muss
den Blick darüber
hinwegrichten und vielleicht darf ich
auf zwei Dinge hinweisen einmal die
Entwicklung in in der israelischen
Regierung selbst sie haben hier ein
Kabinett eine Regierung die
möglicherweise dabei ist die Annektion
des westjorlandlands vorzubereiten also
wenn man die Äußerungen jetzt auch der
Hamas verfolgt geht es nicht nur um um
den gaserstreifen sondern es geht mit
Äußerungen wie äh dass es jetzt äh gilt
die palästinensischen Widerstand zu
vereinen mit dem Widerstand wörtliches
Zitat von heute morgen äh im Libanon
also Hisbollah und im
Irak gibt es schon ein politisch
kalkuliertes Moment glaube ich in einem
einer Situation wo die israelische
Regierung sich radikalisiert und
möglicherweise eine Annektion
vorbereitet äh it natürlich das
endgültige Ende eines zwei eines eines
zwei
staatenlösung eingelutet wäre und dann
gibt's noch die internationale Lage mm
die ein
Prozess ein Prozess der Annäherung
zwischen Saudi-Arabien und Israel
indem es darum geht dass Saudi-Arabien
die Existenz Israels angeht dass
diplomatische Beziehung gibt und auf der
anderen Seite natürlich auch saudiarab
eine gewisse Lösung in in der
Palästinenser Frage anbieten muss und
hier sind bisher äußerern deuten nicht
darauf hin dass Saudi-Arabien das ein
besondere Priorität ist sie haben also
eine ganz bestimmte Lage die vielleicht
den Zeitpunkt dieses dieses Angriffs
erklärt Herr Gerl heute kam aus dem
Libanon von der hisbolla tatsächlich
eine Erklärung die in diese Richtung
ging also das es
tatsächlich um den
Annäherungsprozess der Israelis an
Saudi-Arabien ging könnte das in der Tat
der Grund sein dafür warum der Iran der
ist ja möglicherweise der Strippenzieher
vom ganzen jetzt diesen ja fast schon
Krieg diesen Terror angeordnet haben
mag es gibt nicht einen Grund sondern es
gibt wie hummann gerade richtig gesagt
hat ein ein Zusammenwirken verschiedener
Faktoren die dann natürlich in eine
Situation führen erstmal wenn die
hisbolla tatsächlich jetzt ernst macht
und äh einsteigt in diesen Krieg dann
ähm könnte das könnte die israelische
das israelische Militär die israelischen
Sicherheitskräfte und auch die
technologischen Abwehrsysteme
tatsächlich überfordert werden das würde
sie tatsächlich an die Grenzen der
belast Belastbarkeit bringen es würde
zwar
Tod und und und verderben und Zerstörung
über den Libanon bringen auch aber das
ist durchaus eine ernstzunehmende Gefahr
ähm ich denke es ist tatsächlich so es
kann ein politischer Erfolg der Hamas
werden eben diesen Annäherungsprozess zu
torpedieren und zu verhindern denn was
jetzt passiert wird ist dass Israel mit
einer mit mit mit mit mit heftiger
militärischer Macht in Gaza eingreifen
wird es ist auch mit dem Einsatz von
Bodentruppen zu rechnen das wird viele
palästinensische Opfer fordern und dass
der saudische Grund Mohammed bin Salman
in dieser Situation den Israelis die
Hand reicht und sagt wir geben jetzt
auch dem amerikanischen Druck nach und
und normalisieren ohne Vorbedingungen
ist vor diesem Hintergrund relativ
schwer vorstellbar die politischen
Implikationen sind tatsächlich
interessant weil wenn wir 50 Jahre
zurückgucken in den JOM kipurkrieg und
sie haben die Symbolik des Datums
angesprochen damals haben die Araber
auch äh viele Opfer gelassen aber haben
das als ein notwendige Maßnahme
interpretiert um Israel in zu zu
Verhandlungen zu zwingen und zu
Konzessionen zu zwingen deswegen kann
ich mir vorstellen dass dieses Kalkül
auch auf hamass Seite besteht dass man
auch wenn man Opfer bringen muss jetzt
eine militärische Eskalation
vorantreibt um eben politisch wieder
handlungsfähiger zu sein entscheidend
ist aber das ist mein letzter Punkt den
ich noch machen möchte die
entführungsaktionen die die Hamas durch
führt hat inklusive nach unbestätigten
Berichten sollen auch soll mindestens
auch ein hochrangiger Militär Israels
entführt worden sein die machen es für
die Israelis jetzt schwerer mit der
gewohnten Härte oder noch größerer Härte
zuzuschlagen denn sie wissen dass wenn
Sie jetzt eine groß angelegte
Militäroperation in Gasa durchführen
dann gefährden sie auch das Leben der
israelischen Geiseln und das ist
natürlich perfide aber strategisch auch
muss man leider sagen brilant geplant
von der Hamas weil sie den Israelis
damit eben auch ein gewisses
Eskalationspotenzial nimmt ja Herr
gellach danke für den Moment danke Herr
Humann für den Moment wir reden gleich
weiter jetzt wollen wir uns aber mal
anschauen was der israelische
Ministerpräsident netanahu heute morgen
zu der aktuellen Situation seines Landes
zu sagen
hatte her Bürger Israel wir sind im
Krieg also das ist keine Operation es
ist Krieg wir sind richtig im Krieg
heute hat Hamas eröffnet Feuer das Feuer
gegen state Israel wir sind drinne und
seit dem früh
Morgenstunden und ich habe alles gesagt
dass alles alle eingedrungene
Terroristen sollen raus und vernichtet
werden und wir werden zurück einen Krieg
führen und wir werden etwas D tun was
der Feind bis jetzt noch nicht gekannt
hat ich sage allen
jetzt hören Sie gut auf was was wir an
Weisung geben durch wir sind im Krieg
und wir werden diesen Krieg auch
gewinnen ja soweit der israelische
Präsident Netanyahu heute morgen also da
wird jetzt möglicherweise eine größere
Militäraktion her human der Israelis
folgen müssen auf diese Situation wir
haben schon gerade darüber gesprochen
wir haben ja auch diesen brennenden
Panzer
gesehen das ist offenbar wirklich ein
sehr gezielter Schlag von der Hamas und
anderen
Terroristen im Hintergrund wirkt der
Iran mit dieses theokratische Regime in
Tehran warum ist es so welches Interesse
haben diese mullas die ja seit Monaten
vor allem auch die Frauen im Iran wieder
knechten und terorisieren teilweise
ermorden warum hat dieses Regime in
Teran so ein großes Interesse daran die
gesamte Region zu destabilisieren und
mit Terror zu überziehen ich glaube um
es ein bisschen zu überspitzen was wir
schon seit Jahren erleben vor dieser
Annäherung zwischen Saudi-Arabien und
Israel den Abrams
Abkommen die ja von Trump noch dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten initiiert
worden sind haben wir eine Konkurrenz
von Iran bisschen überspitz gesagt und
Saudi-Arabien
über eine Führungsrolle im Nahen Osten
iranischen Streitkräfte sind nicht auf
dem Stand der saudiarabischen und sie
versuchen diese Führungsrolle mit äh mit
der Unterstützung von Organisation
wieder Hisbollah und jetzt auch dem
Islamischen Jihad der übrigens auf der
Seite der Hamas ist aus und sind auch
die haben auch diese Raketen geliefert
also die Hamas konnte ja seit längerem
auch die husbol
aufrüsten die Hamas mit finanzieller
Hilfe von Qatar und die Raketen kommen
aus dem Iran also wir haben diese immer
wieder Konkurrenzsituation die Iran mit
diesem Mittel versucht hier eine
Führungsrolle
vielen Dank für den Moment wir wollen
mal nachhören wie aktuell die Situation
in Israel ist ich begrüße
schalik er ist ehemaliger Sprecher der
israelischen Armee und heute als
Schriftsteller tätig guten Tag Herr
schallika wunderschönen guten Tag nach
Berlin oder Bonn nach Bonn genau sie
sind in Tel
Aviv wie ist aktuell die Lage bei ihnen
in Tel Aviv Tel Aviv und die aktuell was
hören Sie wie ist die Lage im
Land ja leider in Israel ist die Lage
gerade ziemlich schwierig seit heute
früh wurde Israel überrascht mit
Raketenbeschuss was an sich eigentlich
keine Neuigkeit ist kommt ja immer mal
wieder vor aber 3000 Raketen inhalb von
weniger Stunden das ist schon übler
Terror der hier über halb Israel
hereingebrochen ist in zukommt dass
einige Dutzend Terroristen tatsächlich
nach Israel eingedrungen sind mit Pickup
trcks und anderen auf anderen Wegen und
hier
äh tatsächlich äh Mord und Todschlag
verübt haben und so wie es aussit auch
mehrere Israelis und israelinnen
entführt haben was hören sie denn welche
Erklärung hat denn das israelische
Militär bzw die Regierung da dafür wie
es zu diesem doch sehr großen
Terrorangriff kommen konnte wir haben
z.B Bilder gesehen äh aus Gaza vom
Grenzzaun mit einem brennenden Panzer
wie konnte es zu solchen Aktionen der
Terroristen
kommen also da gibt's sehr viele
Erklärungen für die alle zusammen kommen
einmal wir haben jetzt genau 50-jähriges
Jubiläum des JOM kipur Krieges 1973
fällt genau auf dieses Wochenende
hinzukommt dass natürlich die
friedensverhandlung zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und dem und Israel das
Mulla Regime im Iran enorm unter Druck
setzen äh weil hier immer mehr arabische
Staaten und Israel sich verbünden und
natürlich äh das islamische Regime im
Iran äh sich äh in die
Ecke gedrängt fühlt und all seine
Terroristen jetzt natürlich auf die
Beine stellt unter anderem die Hamas und
den Islamischen Jihad in Gazastreifen
das sind Proxis vom Muller Regime im
Iran äh dann kommt natürlich hinzu dass
die Hamas und der islamische dihad immer
mal wieder liefern müssen das sind
Terrororganisationen sie können
eigentlich nichts anderes sie bauen
keine Krankenhäuser sie bauen keine
Schulen keine Kinder Gärten das einzige
was sie tun ist Raketen positionieren äh
terrortunnel bauen und wie wir jetzt
gesehen haben tatsächlich mit Kommandos
maskierten Männern nach Israel
einbringen und Frauen und Männer hier
ermorden und
kidnappen sie sagen die Terroristen
müssen immer mal wieder reagieren
vermutlich auch um ihre Geldgeber und
Unterstützer äh zu befriedigen heißt das
aus ihrer Sicht sie denken dass es jetzt
äh nach Militäraktionen durch die
Israelis während wir hier sprechen sehen
wir Rauchwolken über Gaza Stadt dass es
die eine oder andere vielleicht größere
Militäraktion jetzt geben wird aber dass
ich danach sozusagen die Lage in dieser
schwierigen Situation Israels in
gewisser Hinsicht normalisiert oder
womit rechnen
Sie also normalisieren wird es sich
heute morgen leider noch nicht so wie es
ausschaut wird es in den nächsten Tagen
vielleicht sogar Wochen äh
Kampfhandlungen geben
äh es wird äh hier keinen Weg zurück
geben zu gestern weil was die Hamas und
der islamischen dihad hier angestellt
haben äh jetzt schon über 20 ermordete
Israelis
Menschen die gekidnappt wordden die
misshandelt wurden also was hier
passiert ist heute das ist nicht so
einfach so dahinzuspülen
und ich nehme an dass in den nächsten
Tagen Wochen hier sehr viel passieren
wird leider und die chamas und der
islamische dihad das sind zwei
palästinensische Terrororganisationen
einen schweren Preis dafür bezahlen
werden was genau die israelische Armee
und Israel als Staat tun werden
kann ich so nicht sagen weil ich selber
jetzt noch nicht weiß weil die Politik
in Israel das auch noch jetzt im
Gespräch ausmachen muss und das
israelische Militär natürlich alle
möglichen Pläne vorlegen muss was getan
werden sollte
und dann natürlich in Zusammenarbeit mit
unseren Freunden und Verbündeten auf der
Welt ein für alle Mal hoffentlich auch
Schluss machen mit diesen
Terrororganisationen die Israel immer
mal wieder an die Kehle wollen alle paar
Jahre und das kann nicht immer so
weitergehen ja Herr schalika sie
sprechen die Freunde Israels an dazu
zählt ja auch Deutschland der Kanzler
zeigt sich heute entsetzt in einer
Erklärung ebenso wie die Außenministerin
Frau berbaug und sag man sagt man steht
an der Seite Israels reicht das im
Moment sozusagen diese
Solidaritätsbekundung die aus der ganzen
Welt übrigens auch aus Kiev kommen oder
sagen Sie in dieser Situation muss jetzt
mehr beispielsweise aus Europa an
Unterstützung kommen
ja also erstmal ich bedanke mich bei
allen die Solidarität zeigen und das
laut und deutlich klar machen dass sie
an der Seite eines demokratischen freien
Staates stehen gegen Terroristen ähäh
dafür erstmal großen Dank auch an die
deutsche Politik aber man kann jetzt
nicht heute Solidarität kund geben und
am nächsten Tag dann Millionen Euros
rüberfließen lassen in den
gaserestreifen angeblich um dort
Menschen zu helfen wobei wir doch alle
sehen wohin das Geld am Ende gelangt ich
persönlich möchte auch dass den Menschen
im Gazastreifen natürlich gut geht ich
will dass die Palästinenser in Frieden
leben können aber die Ursache für Terror
und Krieg sowohl in Israel als auch in
den palästinensischen Gebieten das sind
die Terroristen das sind
Terrororganisationen allen voran
natürlich das Muller Regime im Iran und
solange da Gelder fließen werden die am
Drücker bleiben und derartige Aktion
immer wieder ausführen und da reichen
leider nicht nur nette äh Tweets und
Posts auf Facebook sondern da muss auch
mal klar Kante gezeigt werden sagt arje
schallika ehemaliger Sprecher der
israelischen Armee und heute als
Schriftsteller tätig ich sage Danke nach
telaviv für ihre
Zeit ja da kommt eine klare Forderungen
Forderung aus Tel Aviv Richtung
Europäische Union auch Richtung
Bundesregierung es muss Schluss sein mit
der finanziellen Unterstützung für den
Gazastreifen für die Palästinenser ich
weiß jetzt nicht um wie viel Millionen
Summen es hier geht was die Europäische
Union und Deutschland zusammenzahlen
aber sind erkläckliche Summen finden Sie
diese Forderung richtig oder würden Sie
sagen gerade jetzt in der Situation
müssen eventuell so es sieht denn noch
gibt moderate Kräfte in im gaserstreifen
unterstützt werden also ich kann Herrn
schallik vielen zustimmen in einem
vielleicht nicht ganz
äh der Terrorismus ist nicht der einzige
Grund für die für diese Zuspitzung der
Situation das ist auch die Lage der
Palästinenser im Westjordanland und im
Gazastreifen
das würde ich gerne ergänzen und was die
Hamas angeht die
Bundesregierung als Teil der EU hat
Hamas als terroristische Organisation
eingestuft beteiligt sich aber an einer
Finanzierung der palestinensischen
Autonomiebehörde also leistet hier
Entwicklungshilfe
ähm
aber wenn der Bundeskanzler Solidarität
betont ist das politisch gemeint die
Frage ist wie wenn die palästinenserfage
auf die politische Agenda kommt wie wir
uns da
Verhalten auch noch mal an diese Frage
an Herrn Gerl zugeschaltet aus Berlin
was ist aus ihrer Sicht jetzt das Gebot
der Stunde der internationalen
Gemeinschaft vor allem vielleicht auch
der Politik in
Berlin schau sie wir kennen diese Muster
das das läuft ja immer nach demselben
Verfahren ab es gibt eine es gibt eine
Provokation es gibt Ankündigung jetzt
gibt's keinen Weg mehr zurück sie sehen
jetzt schon einige Stimmen in den
sozialen Medien die sagen das ist der
Krieg der alles verändern wird Nago sagt
jetzt werdet ihr einen Krieg erleben wie
ihr ih noch nie erlebt habt dann wird es
viel Zerstörung geben es wird viele Tote
geben dann wird man doch wieder auf die
Kräfte zurückgreifen die eben Mediation
betreiben und ä dann ist es leider so zu
befürchten dass die Situation dann doch
beim Alten bleibt außer dass eben einige
Menschen gestorben sind und viel Schaden
angerichtet wurde und ähm natürlich ist
die Palästinenser Frage und die die die
der der ungelöste naostkonflikt ähm der
hintergrund dieser Entwicklung und die
internationale Politik hat sich da
eigentlich ziemlich rausgezogen wenig
Hoffnung gemacht und wenn man sich die
Amerikaner anschaut als die große
vermittlungsmacht äh die haben in
letzter Zeit interessanterweise unter
Joe Biden nur noch darauf Wert gelegt
die Normalisierung zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Israel voranzutreiben
haben erheblichen diplomatischen Druck
ausgeübt um im Grunde das Werk zu
vollenden was was äh beidens Vorgänger
Donald Trump angefangen hat und das
genügt natürlich nicht zur Lösung des
des Palästinenser des
palästinerkonflikts das Problem ist nur
in einer solchen Situation der
Eskalation hat man gar keine politischen
Hebel um in irgendeiner Form an einer
nachhältigen Friedenslösung zu arbeiten
sondern kann eben nur kurzfristig
versuchen
äh die die weitere die Ausweitung des
Konfliktes zu verhindern und da fürchte
ich hat Deutschland relativ wenig zu
beizutragen denn militärisch ist es so
dass Deutschland momentan eigentlich
eher
von Israel abhängig ist und von
israelischer Technologie als umgekehrt
bei den Amerikaner ist es was anderes
aber ich denke nicht dass man hier die
Möglichkeiten und auch Handhabe hat um
auf diesen Konflikt in irgendeiner Form
sinnvollen Einfluss auszuüben sagt
Daniel Gerlach zugeschaltet aus Berlin
der ostexperte ich sage danke dafür und
danke für Ihre Zeit für den Moment
anzita Humann der Sicherheitsexperte bei
ihnen bedanke ich mich ebenfalls bis
hierhin vielen Dank ja das war Phönix
vort mit der ersten Sondersendung heute
dazu weitere werden folgen die nächste
um 14:15 Uhr mit meinem Kollegen Tobias
Ufer bleiben Sie bitte bei uns denn wir
befassen uns auch jetzt weiterhin mit
dem Konflikt in im gelobten Land bis
[Musik]
dann